نعم عندما وصلنا الى هذا الموقع مساء امس
تقريبا وصلنا الى هنا في تمام الساعه
الثامنه بالتوقيت المحلي تقريبا كل
الكوادر التي كانت موجوده هم من كوادر
محليه من الاتراك لكن حتى الاليات التي
نشاهدها الان الاليات الثقيله لم تقم بهذا
العدد وهذا الكم لكن عندما كان هناك بصيص
امل بوجود اشخاص على قيد الحياه وكما
تحدثنا قبل قليل سمعوا مرتين مساء امس
اصوات من تحت الانقاض واشتعل هذا المكان
الذي نتواجد فيه فرحا بوجود اشخاص ناجين
تم طلب تعزيزات ان اتحدث عن اعداد ضعف
الاعداد التي كانت متواجده امس من ناحيه
عدد الاشخاص او حتى عدد الاليات طبعا من
بين
المعدات الموجوده من ضمن المعدات الموجوده
ايضا عفوا من ضمن الكوادر الموجوده هناك
خبراء اجانب وفرق انقاذ اجنبيه قدموا الى
هنا للمشاركه والمساعده طبعا كما تحدثت
قبل قليل احضروا معهم كلاب مدربه واجهزه
استشعار هذه الاجهزه هي التي كشفت وهذه
الكلاب هي التي حددت ايضا الموقع الذي
ترصدها الكاميرا الان وطلب الخبراء من
الجميع الحفر هنا لكن بادوات بسيطه دون
استخدام اليات ثقيله الاليات والرافعات
الثقيله فقط هي تقوم برفع الكتل الخرسانيه
الضخمه يعني الجميع يعمل هنا وفق اشراف
الفريق المختص
[موسيقى]